hello welcome back to youtube gaming
right here at PAX Prime 2015 I'm your
host Daniel dwyer from gamespot com
delighted be joined by the Madame
subjects on the practice games how you
doing sir very happy to be here I'm good
I'm good enjoying your packs experience
so far I am I am yeah my eye I took a
plane ride here sitting like busted my
eardrums great sides that I love pie
haven't popped yet ya know all right
maybe it'll happen during this next 90
minutes we're gonna talk about XCOM 2
alright so if I start screaming and
rolling on the ground yeah it's probably
what's good it's good internet video yes
what is that yeah this hit that add book
helps everybody that helps everybody and
so 2012 ex-con came out like fantastic
rebirth of a series of I adored for
years and years and were you guys
surprised that has successful XCOM laws
because you reached like fans like me of
the series you played them all but it
really like sold to everyone even on
like tablets and everything yeah I mean
yeah I think there was some trepidation
at least from me personally and you do
something like that and you you wonder
it is there an audience for this you
know we believe it was a good game but
it was different it's a very different
game you know and so we wanted you know
is there gonna be an audience and so
there was a little trepidation there but
we were very very blessed to have to
have the reception and had and it has a
great audience and so it's really really
fortunate and we've got a bunch of
footage from XCOM 2 which we're going to
this boy at the moment I see a little
bit of news this morning as well you
guys have pushed it back to at
February's 2016 right yes februari fifth
yeah yeah and it's you know we've we
play through the game a bunch of times
and so now we're just sort of put just a
little extra love on it and make it just
as good a game it could be and so the
setup freqs come to is that you didn't
do so well on ExComm one right that's
right that's right so the idea is that
you know this sort of story behind it is
that XCOM did not win in the first game
and so the way I say this and maybe this
just helps me is
that every time you start up a new game
of X gum it's kind of like you're
spinning off an alternate universe and
we are taking over the story from the
universe's where maybe players lost and
yeah in the game like X come that
happened a fair amount so if you One X
come then exhale I'm to never happened
in your universe but in this verse yeah
then we're giving you a chance to go
back and sort of uh sort of help and now
all the aliens are underwater oh yes
that's how I seek that's alright your
secret announcement yeah no there isn't
Tara from the deep to the zone good but
you are basically sort of your forced
underground in a manner of speaking but
you're sort of on the back foot now
right yeah we wanted to kind of flip
everything so the idea is that instead
of the aliens striking quickly and then
fading away now that's X comes jobs the
earth belongs to the alien so you're
kind of invading earth you know from the
perspective of this resistance movement
and so we've kind of flipped everything
around so you attack quickly and then
try to fade away the aliens are kind of
hunting you so how does that work that
in terms of like mission set up and
stuff because instead of like going to
like flash points for aliens are like
you know the idea of taking down an
intercept or intercepting is right yeah
so there there are some missions of
opportunity you know so you may have a
couple missions of opportunity where you
could receive different rewards and then
there are sometimes the engines may
strike back and then you have to you're
forced to take a mission and then the
aliens have you know they are actually
building up strength around the world as
well and so you'll see these alien bases
around the world and you can even target
those and take them out and you'll have
to because an X come to the aliens are
actually playing in the game and so they
have a victory condition from themselves
oh wow you have a victory condition
Valens have a victory condition and so
they have a lot of like short term
strategies and long-term strategies and
so now you get kind of to balance I want
to do this so this helps me but at the
same time I've got to strike the image
at these different locations sort of
pull them back excellent what are the
sort of main I guess tenants of the
series in terms of like getting your
funding and stuff was obviously
allocating the various aspects of the
right is that still an integral part of
its different now because again sort of
like flipping everything you start with
in X come to you start with almost
nothing done in X come you kind of had
to control the entire world yet to keep
it really happy and Exum to you start
with nothing and you build it up and so
I actually kind of building everything
up into this new resistance and so it's
kind of again reverse so you have to
sort of add strength as you go along and
here you see the new base and it looks
kind of like the base from X gone but
the difference is this space can fly it
can fly you can fly yes believe in
yourself is it flying right now or you
can you move it like you move like
starcraft 2 endgame yeah it like it
right yeah it's basically like that so
you move it from different locations for
different opportunities you look in the
different rumors you're on the run until
you move it to a location another region
as you sort of make contact with more of
the world you can fly around and look at
the different things and so then you
land and then you do stuff like this
build stuff research stuff standard
exhales thanks so what's what I guess
stage of the invasion are we coming in
at like how they just one has like 10
years past about 20 years old oh wow yes
and no [ __ ] [ __ ] Scott there were there
in egg Queens who have never seen a
world at anything right that's right and
so yeah and almost drinking yeah yeah oh
look well actually maybe in the alien
future you can drink at 50 i don't know
maybe anything like isn't so bad after
all i haven't dug deep into the cannon
actually but yeah so the idea is that
the aliens have reformed earth and they
have these beautiful cities that they've
sort of built over our old cities um but
you know they're aliens they're not good
people wait not it people at all are
they populated by alien civilians that
you're going to murder no no there's no
like alien civilian murder well oh just
alien murdering that makes it sound
terrible you're twisting my words no um
so the people they go to these cities
you know but of course there's a there's
a dark side of the city right people are
going missing you know as aliens tend to
do okay yeah go missing it it's up to
you to sort of reveal the truth of
what's going on
yeah it's abe's oddysee exists my head's
turnin ASA Cleveland's heavily heavily
inspired at so we're looking here at the
right the on-farm yes and this is the
proving grounds and so a lot of what we
wanted to do design-wise is make the
game a lot more open-ended and sort of
you know you have these experiences that
are different from game to game and so
this is a silly called the proving
grounds and you can go in there you can
choose to build experimental ammo or
grenades and you don't know what you're
going to get you just get something
awesome but it allows you every time you
play that these different experiences
and that sort of goes through the entire
design if we really wanted the game to
be unexpected every time you play you
get these sort of unexpected me as some
sort of the core experience still
getting in at your guys and girls
leveling them up so yeah izing people
yeah I mean that the cord spirits is
similar where you know you have research
you have engineering and then you have
your soldiers and we see here like our
souls ii chin-ups yeah these got
something i can't do one of those yeah
you look alien rule to your world you'd
have to get tough and reduce your mocap
what's that you mocap ahead yeah that's
me except you don't see the guy
underneath pushing upside down right
yeah you're getting there probably
underwater yeah the soldiers are kind of
the heart of X comb actually hey good
segue because we're not to look at her
soul yeah and what we've done is we've
gone way way way I don't say overboard
that sounds bad but we've done really
deep into customization hmm so you can
totally customize your soldiers and here
you see one of our new soldier class is
the specialist and they got a little pet
Kremlin that does all kinds of like
awesome stuff like hacking computers or
it can heal things from afar but you
have ten doors when you're trying to
when the locus is still coming yes
senator no but that's occasion warrants
my your forehead look at me no with this
done no it does not I can't lie it does
it oh but here you guys in Norway all
yes yes look brick looks Loudoun ssin
his name's Odin son for God's sake but
yeah we've changed you can see you can
put tattoos on your soul
you can put new camo patterns um you
know you see he's got scars on that so
you can apply scar that an alien yeah I
like a obvious that was got a lot out of
shaving accident that's and he's got
like the awesome hairdo we've got yeah
well you know there's no real in
cornrows yeah and you can change their
attitude this is like my favorite you
know you can give them like a happy
attitude so we even have like a monocle
we've gone way overboard with customized
and so like all your souls which you can
go crazy with and here you can see
customize your weapons in a while so we
have all these weapon slots you can put
all this different loop that you pick up
off the battlefield and you can even
rename your weapons give them their own
colors patterns all that stuff well what
was the sort of main request that you
guys were hearing from your community
when you're looking into a second game
was it this sort of stuff it was this
came out of everybody's love of their
soldiers and so a lot of times when we
interact with people they would tweet us
pictures of like oh this is my soldier
and she did this and this is her story
and and so we wanted to give people more
props to tell their story because XCOM
has a story but and it's a it's a deep
story it's got all this cinematic really
polished but the idea is that the player
store is the important one and so we
wanted to push that and then the other
side of it too is that to make the game
even more replayable like we're really
big into kind of like time plate for
dollar value right that's a very that's
a very boring way to play yeah I mean it
sounds like a so you're telling me
something right now but I'm but that's
what we believe in at fracks is like we
want people if they're gonna spend money
we want it to be equate with hundreds of
hours of gameplay so we wanted to make
the game more replayable to do that we
get made the game more unpredictable and
more open-ended on the strategy later
yeah and customizing those people like
what I was ended up being such a massive
impetus to keep doing as well because
you're like you've named it after your
buddies and your friends in school I
guess right it works right you watch
them all died horribly yeah it's
wonderful and before let you go what any
changes to like the way combat works we
were walk around or different rooms
different types of NGS into one not how
much time do you have oh no so that yeah
there are a lot of big changes of combat
so just from like the high level it used
to be go kill aliens but
now we have mission objectives so now
it's hack a workstation in Philly how
cool or you know rescue this person and
then ankle any means yeah we don't wanna
get rid of the killing aliens you can't
just kill all of them no not even worry
about i'll just write also do this lip
and kill the aliens um and then we have
loot and so now certain amons drop loot
that you can pick up off the battlefield
we have concealment so your soldiers
start in like a concealment mode you can
sneak up on the amens now actually have
hacking so a no minigame even so oh
really we're one of the first developers
to move into the no minigame pack
breaking ground brave new world right so
yeah then you can use hacking to sort of
change how a comment works and so
there's a lot of like big systems that
we sort of added double the number of
valence almost so their new types new
types a lot of new types of aliens gave
them a lot of new abilities because we
want to have a lot of personality so
yeah we've got aliens then we've got
their little minions called the advent
which are kind of put on in the yellow
file as it look like hydrants are they
what and you say little minions you
don't mean [ __ ] yeah the DLC that'll
be no see right actually that's the boss
of all the aliens it's just a million
factor my my kids would love it sure
they do yeah and ok I don't want to talk
about millions anymore but Jake solemn
it's been a pleasure having you here at
XCOM 2 it's at februari fifth every
fifth 2016 yeah what platforms are the
pc worldwide it's a global relief so an
awesome day you're gonna go down the
tablet route again that was like one of
the when ex-con came out on ipad and
stuff like that's oh yeah i mean not
we're not doing it yet but yeah we're
certainly not opposed to that but hem so
awesome I'm the plug as well you've got
a panel on tomorrow yes yeah I forgot to
plug the panel don't worry you can do it
right now ok alright tomorrow at two
o'clock in the Sasquatch all right the
inner go to the Sasquatch will be giving
a panel where US and the beyond Earth
team we're showing all kinds of new
stuff so we're showing new characters
all kinds of new awesome stuff that we
haven't shown before so it was a good
panel people should show all right two
o'clock tomorrow in the South Scott's
either yes perfect check solemn Roxas
games thank you so much coming on they
appreciate your time enjoy the rest of
your pack sick
I will and thanks to you guys for
watching the show today we've got a
bunch more cool stuff coming on Randy
Pitchford is on pretty soon and Jordan
mr. CaptainSparklez going to gone soon
as well and but yeah we're going to
stick in here we're going to be live for
the next couple of hours at right here
on YouTube gaming at PAX Prime stay
there